I'm happy that we could meet today that
we didn't have to call it off I think
that's a good signal and I won't want to
express my strong appreciation for the
Belgium authorities for keeping us safe
for today first on Greece there is a
situation of the first set of milestones
we now have been implemented one issue
has been moved on to the second set of
milestones which is linked to the
pension reform but all the other issues
have been dealt with and that opens up
the possibility transfer the two billion
disbursements connected to that is of
course the money reserved for the
recapitalisation of the banks the formal
decision on the transfer of the required
funds will be taken by the ESM board of
directors as required we don't know the
exact figures yet and following the
relevant state eight decisions which the
Commission will have to take on a
case-by-case basis on the draft budget
reef lands this is the third year
running that the Eurogroup has met to
discuss the Commission's opinions on
draft petraju plans I will come the fact
that your group broadly concurs with our
assessment as I stated last week we are
now in a situation where most countries
are either compliant or broadly
compliant the neutral stance in the euro
area 0 is broadly appropriate it's
neutral given the need to balance the
objectives and to ensure long-term
fiscal sustainability and to sustain the
economic recovery which is underway in
the euro area